[Music]
the next 10,000 years is a longer time
than people usually think most most
people manages of gaash in a century
from now well that's not big enough but
it's like thinking about just your state
or just your continent
could be thinking about the whole earth
the whole planet and the whole planet is
the big here in the next 10,000 years is
the little glimpse of the long now I
wasn't until I got involved with the
long now that I even had the capacity
for my mind to fathom what ten thousand
years in the future might be and and I
feel like that's impacted just the way I
see the world now I can see it more long
term because involved with an
organization that is
with that zero
like place holder in front of the year
we're always it's an it's an indicator
it doesn't end here I personally think a
lot about the values that we will leave
our
next generation the families that we
will have and the changes that we could
make on this planet good and
I think that thinking about the next
10,000 years matters because we
fundamentally wish that people from our
past cared about us and if we can't
start that cycle of caring about our
future
then nobody well someone has to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you